Now it is time for a pick from the little yellow book,
my personal guide to things
I think would make your life better.
Okay, and today it's an absolutely essential digital helper
that we might all need.
The Washington Post's brand new Help Desk.
They have gathered the crack team of tech reporters
to answer all of your questions about how to get
not only the most out of your technology, but security.
They show you how to do everything step-by-step
and here's their post on how to improve your privacy.
Something, this is very important to me.
Please look at this.
Go to settings and privacy on the website
or on the app, settings, ads, ad settings,
and you're gonna click on
data about your activity from partners.
You're gonna turn this off for Facebook and Instagram.
I mean, that's just one of so many elements.
They'll tell you how to close windows.
Say you don't agree, ask you not to track apps across.
This is really pertinent information
so that we can live the most private life possible
while living in George Orwell's 1984.
So Ross, did you have a tech question.
Yeah, uh huh, uh huh.
So it's been a month and I can't log into Facebook.
So help.
What's a two step authentication code?
Tweet me, not on Facebook because I can't get into it.
Tweet me @HelloRoss and let me know.
I don't, I can't figure it out.
So my grandma, she's posting pictures.
I'm not seeing them, Grandma.
This Help Desk from The Washington Post
and you know they're gonna get it as right as they can,
I think is a great tip for the little yellow book.
Yeah, we all need it.
Yes, we do.
Well, I just want to thank everybody
for joining us today here in the studio.
For choosing your time to spend it with us
and to those at home and on the go.
The most important thing about this whole hour
is we just want you to take it with you
and have a fantastic day, everyone.
(upbeat music)